hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 22nd 2018 what's going on
how are you Hawaii
how's it going how's it going all right
all right let's just get right down to
what the New England Patriots are going
to the Super Bowl again super Oh
un-fuckin'-believable how many times can
they win games like that it's incredible
I thought the officiating was great
everything was great fantastic I liked
how it all washed out I really enjoyed
that referee laughing his ass off after
we scored a touchdown that was
tremendous I love everybody who saw that
ref cracking up laughing which you are
not supposed to do by the way as a
referee and that guy will definitely get
disciplined because what happens is
every mouth breathing more and goes oh
the game's fixed he's laughing cuz they
just you know like which I understand
that is the knee-jerk reaction but think
about what you're saying all right let's
just say for the sake of argument that
referee was was on the take all right
which you know God knows I always said
that about the NBA and then they caught
that guy and everybody said I
was nuts all right
put yourself in that guy's position all
right judging by his age you probably
I'm gonna assume he had a wife and kids
he's got a mortgage he's got a house and
he's risking all of that and his freedom
right now to fix an NFL game put
yourself in that position are you gonna
be laughing when the team scores or
you're gonna be stone-faced are
you really gonna be sitting there going
yeah you know so I'm hoping the NFL
films will come out just to hear what
what whatever Patriots said that made
him laugh because he's got to get in
trouble for that because that opened
this floodgate everybody was just saying
like oh look at all the penalties on
this side
I still don't like the ticky tack pass
and inference stuff however having said
all of that you know I think the Jaguars
defense was a little overrated everybody
kept talking about how great
their defense was and completely ignored
that the week before they gave up 42
points to the Steelers in the
playoffs when it counted everyone just
kept talking about how great their
thief but that defense is that
the only reason why nobody really
brought that up was because they
their offense scored 45 points
so I don't know I don't know what the
to tell you about that great Jaguar
defense they also played in a weak
division they beat the Colts twice
that's why I don't this is this is my
thing okay I'm not saying they don't
have ever they actually do have a great
defense but they're young and they do
dumb things like take stupid penalties
right before the half when the home team
whose favorite has only scored three
points that helmet to helmet hit
by the way
stupid penalty big chunk of
yards and then you take a
bonehead pass interference call on the
next play and you basically give the
Patriots a touchdown you give them
hope and then also your great
defense gives up two touchdowns in the
final at six minutes so I don't
know what to tell you
there was a brutal hold call on the
final important offensive play of the
game I will give you that but ok let's
say they call holding there we're gonna
run it the next play you guys are gonna
burn you last timeout we're gonna kick
the ball you're gonna be down on the 10
yard line and you're telling me
what the minute and change Blake bortles
is gonna run the length of the I
mean it could happen it could
happen but I don't know I don't know but
anyways that's why I don't give a
about you know regular season stats you
know I mean okay here's the thing
pumping up the
Jaguars defense regular-season they beat
the Colts without Andrew Luck 27 nothing
they beat the Browns and only gave up
seven points they beat the Colts
again 32 10 they beat the Texans
45 to 7 these are all teams that
you're not going to see in January
alright but if you go through that
season they played the Titans
twice a playoff teams they lost two on
both times led up 37 points and
had a close game at the end of the year
they played the Rams that were a playoff
team they lost to them the only playoff
team that I'm looking at real quick that
they beat was the Pittsburgh Steelers
beat him 32 9 and then they met him in
the play and they led up 42
points so I don't know I mean how much
more advantage could their defense have
I mean Edelman wasn't in the game our
number one receiver
our next number one option was Rob
Gronkowski and you knocked him out you
know on a helmet to helmet hit that if a
patriot did it would have been viewed as
like that like like you killed Christ or
something but whatever it was a great
game Jaguars should have won the game I
just thought they were too young and
didn't know how to win the game didn't
know how to put the Patriots away and I
don't know and Tom Brady's Tom Brady
not to mention Tom Brady also had like I
don't know what the happened guy
cut his hand we have almost 41
year old quarterback with the with the
stitches in his throwing hand
Edelman is out and you knock out
Gronkowski and I don't want to hear what
Gronkowski wasn't doing Gronkowski
does something on every play he draws
double coverage and you didn't have to
deal with that anymore so I
don't know what the to tell you I
do feel bad for Jaguar fans because you
know that's a football city that
nobody seems to give a about you
know what I mean I like to Jax you know
what I've actually come around those
helmets too so it was a great
game
the Patriots are limping into the
Superbowl and should be underdogs but
won't be
has every mouth-breathing who
doesn't know about football will
put money on the Patriots for somehow we
will be a I mean the Eagles just look
like world beaters they have an
amazing defense they have two
beasts they literally have proles and
malcolm Blount I mean I don't
know why the we ever got rid of him
I'm sure there was a reason for it but
yeah I mean the Eagles should be
favorites but they won't be just
historically because it never
won it and we've won a lot so so then if
we lose it's going to be like an
unbelievable upset what does it say
about Brady's legacy we shall see we
shall see and I feel bad for New England
fans they're gonna go to that game with
the behavior of Eagles fans and all of
that
and you know I saw some of the footage
some of this was funny but like I
don't know Philly fans say you know what
they act like do you remember when you
didn't know how to talk to women so you
just went out did crazy
every weekend hoping that the women
would then hear this story and be like
oh that's the guy I want to go out with
I just don't get it man I just don't you
know Vikings fans oh hey how are
y'all are you doing like the
nice Midwest people you're throwing full
beers at them I don't know but on the
other side it's just like you know
that's what you're gonna get why the
would you wear your Vikings gear to
the goddamn game but that's really
getting played out showing that type of
and and they did the classic thing
too you know it's funny with with every
like NFL City there they have like the
story like whenever there's a game in
Boston they have to play that stupid
departed music I'm shipping up
to boston and i lost me leg and then
they're gonna show Paul Revere and if
all this Freedom Trail that nobody
gives a about who lives in Boston I
walk by that statue a million
times I never look
at it and I don't eat clam chowder
anytime filly plays in a major sporting
event at some point some douche
is gonna try to teach you how to order a
Philly cheesesteak
it's like we got it
give me a wiz wit give me one without
don't say Philly cheesesteak you're in
Philly you could literally walk up there
to any cheesesteak place in
Philadelphia be like I would like a
cheese steak with onions and peppers and
provolone cheese and you're gonna get it
because at the end of the day they're a
business and they need your money
they always do that they show the
rocky statue and then they bring
up the fact that they threw
batteries at Santa Claus as if that is
the only thing that has ever
happened in Philadelphia why don't they
ever reenact Ben Franklin supplying that
stupid kite with the key on it
right why don't they bring up the 83
Philadelphia 76ers the most underrated
championship team of all time
who I've said forever that I would put
up against the 96 Bulls okay I would
take dr. Jay and Andrew Tony to
knock down a lot of what Jordan
and what's-his-face are gonna do
Scottie Pippen and then underneath you
got Moses Malone one-on-one
against Luc Longley I'm not saying they
would have one I'm saying you know be a
hell of a Series anyways
congratulations to the to the
Eagles what a game good Lord they that
was they gave them the they gave the
Vikings the old right there Fred I bet
there was a lot of Vikings fans watching
that they just lost to the
Saints after that beatdown he took him
right across their lap
spank their fanny is it weird that I
mean as much as I love the Vikings I
kind of was rooting for the Eagles just
because I don't know Case Keenum I just
can't get past that name Case Keenum it
just makes me still feel so old
somebody named a kid case couldn't just
name Robert sorry I'm being a so
anyways if you are a Patriots fan
yeah just know that you know it's it's
going to be a terrible fan experience
because nobody does anything about that
level of ridiculous behavior and
I think at this point they get so much
hype out of how bad they behave
they're like trying to outdo one another
like you remember a few years ago there
was like some off-duty cop went to like
a Phillies game and this guy was
swearing and behind him and he goes
hey take it easy I got my kid here and
the guy put his fingers down his throat
and threw up on the guy's kid I mean at
that point it's just like he's just
doing that just to do it right
I don't know so anyway so now we're
gonna have to sit through two
goddamn weeks of them talking about
throwing batteries at Santa
Claus and showing the Paul
Revere statue and I'm shipping up to
boston and i lost me like i don't know i
think the Eagles are an overwhelming
favorite if people knew how to gamble on
football I would think but that's not
how it works but I think it's definitely
it's the Eagles game to lose I
might be crazy but that's that's
definitely what I think but all right so
there you go that's there's my there's
my football talk condolences to the
jaguars and Vikings fans you
know what I'm actually excited to watch
is that thing where they have some
Thursday on CBS about the
NFL players like who's like the most
tooth like basically whatever your hobby
is they got guys in the NFL playing
drums guitar cooking and I actually
want to watch that because I want to see
how good the football player drummers
are stupid is that right oh whatever you
got a thousand channels you got
to find something to watch right anyways
did you guys see that the
is that that that one-year anniversary I
forgot member that lady when Trump got
in who was just screaming no I don't
understand that that type of protest to
do something like that because I think a
lot of people were thinking that but to
literally do what that woman did makes
anybody who doesn't like Trump look like
a lunatic you know there's so
much just weird like that like I
saw last night the SAG Awards had all
women presenters
I just for the life of
me
who comes up with this all of it
just seems like self-preservation to me
and none of it seems like you're
actually gonna work on the problem like
that's all the SAG Awards have to
do is just have all female
presenters and be like yeah see that
they're all good people over there they
get it it's a show of solidarity it's a
show of strength I don't know I think
it's a pretty weak effort you
know we're gonna wear all black tuxedos
we're gonna wear if we're gonna have all
female presenters there we go
we've been vetted I hate that word by
the way
yeah that's that's the whole
thing it's just I mean who the foo is
pro sexual harassment why would you need
to go that much out of your way to do
something as silly as that which in a
lot of ways is kind of reverse sexist
isn't it I don't know here's one
thing about this this is the only
business I know about it's this business
that I'm in this business
brutal and it routinely picks
people up and slams them against the
pavement emotionally every day
regardless of what's between you between
your legs I don't know all right I don't
I don't even know what I'm trying to say
here I just look at it I'm like well
they just decided they were gonna have
all-male presenters that would be
considered the most sexist thing ever
and and then on the other side if you
want all this all these creeps
well let's be specific only the male
creeps in Hollywood if you want all of
them out I don't know that that's the
way to do it if that's an
effective way to do it everywhere buddy
wears the same colored shirt and you
have all women presenters you know I
don't have a I don't have a degree in
fighting crime for whatever that degree
is but I don't think same colored shirts
is going to do it we have to stop Isis
okay
everybody wear blue shirts on Tuesday
he's not wearing a blue shirt does that
mean he's in Isis it's not what it is
built its as its as its symbolism it's a
sign of strength oh Jesus
all right maybe that is what it is I
have no idea this is this why
this is why I watch sports
i watch sports so once again the
New England Patriots they're in their
10th Super Bowl they have a
chance to win their sixth Superbowl
literally what Tom Brady Belichick and
these guys are doing as much as you guys
hate them and every time
we win a game there's some giant goddamn
conspiracy because nobody will give it
up that they're a great team
what they've done at this point has
transcended the game of football all
right you got to put him up there with
like the I would say the Yankees
from DiMaggio to Mickey Mantle that run
there with the amount of World Series
that they went to the amount that they
won
the Canadians back in the day the
Celtics in the 60s I mean that's
literally what you're watching and for
them to be doing it now you know the
reason why that never happens anymore is
because now there's like 30
teams and every basically every sport
it's just too it's too difficult to do
and somehow they are doing it so as much
as you hate him can you at least give it
up on that are you just gonna set it up
we're gonna start weighing footballs
again and I don't know I don't
know all right speaking of the Canadian
say oh you watch any Bruins Canadiens
games lately we now we beat him
three times in the last eight days and
the only reason why I know that is
because Joe bartnik from the the great
puck off podcast told me I've been so
goddamn busy I only watched the first
period of one of the games I've missed
so much Bruins hockey this and I know
they're playing great and they're on
this amazing streak and pretty excited
that they beat the Canadiens three times
in the last eight games I know I have
all the games taped so I'm gonna I'm
gonna have to watch them in like one
period segments not because I because I
got the kiddo at home but uh I haven't
said that everybody knows the regular
season doesn't mean you know and
Regulus I'm telling you regular season
stats just go back to somebody scheduled
and look at what they did against
playoff teams and even then I think in
football gives you a little bit more of
a gauge but like in basketball baseball
and hockey it's I don't think it means
because on any given night anything
play so many games any team can beat
another team but winning in the playoffs
and winning four out of seven is it's a
whole different ballgame so I just wish
more announcers would do that you
know I mean look at the division like
even the like look at the Patriots for
how many years we've gotten all these
double-digit wins the AFC East
has been so goddamn weak so many years
so many years like the Jets who by the
way beat the Jag was in the regular
season the
Jetts suck the Dolphins have
sucked in the Bills have sucked so many
those gave Gibson you know or at least
mediocre and that has given us five to
six wins every year anyway
alright I'm done I'm done with I'm done
with the goddamn sports let's talk about
it was my daughter
it was my daughter's first birthday this
this past weekend I can't believe it
she's already won she's no longer a baby
she's a toddler which is pretty amazing
and I gotta be honest with you it's a
little sad you know what I mean
she's now motoring around the house and
I don't know it's already going by way
too fast and so anyways it was her
birthday right so I decided you know
every year for her birthday is it dad
I'm gonna make her a homemade cake and I
did it and we had like Mia invited all
of these people like it's weird like all
of our friends a bunch of our friends I
should say had kids in like the last
year like the last three years so we had
16 little kids over here plus their
parents and a few of them brought
friends like we had like a we had we had
a house party but it was just kids it
was awesome the kids were it was it was
amazing man they just blew my mind cuz
I'm sitting there was like 30 people in
my house at least and I remember
standing there thinking like wow like
literally like a year and a half ago
this would have been a bunch of guys
sitting here smoking cigars on the back
porch drinking booze and now I got all
these these kids running around all of
this stuff and I got to tell you after
watching all the kids I'm kind of
psyched I had a daughter do little girls
that are made they're like little adults
they just they sit there they're
emotionally stable the little boys that
they're lunatics they're running
all over the place
they're quiet I got this
fountain out in my front yard and I know
that that sounds wild bill wow you got a
fountain in your front yard you know
what I would say about our fountain go
back and watch that Fred Armisen sketch
on SNL when he does the thing marble
columns when they were talking about
putting marble columns on the front of
split-entry houses I hate this
fountain
I've never liked it it's just a giant
it's it's like a it's just a
giant place for mosquitoes to
and give us West Nile virus you know
what I mean but they give you though
then you've got to buy these little
doughnuts of poison that you
throw in there and then a bird comes by
and drinks out of it and then the bird
dies so I never have any water in this
so these boys run out there they climb
it up on the thing I'm having a
panic attack that one of them is gonna
fall down you get him off of that then
they're throwing rocks down to the
driveway hitting the cars yeah I
couldn't get I you know they're little
kids so I didn't get upset up but I was
just like wow man this is uh having a
girl is a lot easy on the parenting
thing I mean they sit down they're like
chill they're thinking you know the boys
are just like hilarious I don't know you
turn your back one of them's gonna be I
got an idea what if I jump through the
screen door so I don't know made me feel
lucky again
so everybody gathers around to sing
happy birthday and I got this cake that
I made and I've never made a cake before
and I didn't I didn't try it out I
didn't want to test a slice and have a
giant slice taken out so I was basically
gonna have 30 people all taste the cake
in front of me and I was waiting for
this tastes like the cakes to dry
or whatever but uh fortunately everybody
seemed to like the cake and after that
the whole party was downhill that was
that was like the big thing I was just
like I just have to get Pat I gotta get
on the other side of the cake here
people eat the cake and they actually
like it God knows if my wife didn't
she would have let me know you know well
in fact she did try the frosting the
night before and she let me know that
she thought it could have been a little
more charm it just tastes sweet I just
wish there was more cocoa in it you know
what I mean and I just went like yeah
and then had like a full-on
panic attack you know it's like why
would you tell me that you know I'm
stressing about this I don't know
that's what they do that's what they do
what what would they be doing if they
weren't criticizing us why can't
there be an award show about that where
they protest the lack of compliments a
man gets the second he marries a woman I
[Laughter]
don't give a if my wife cooked her
shoe how does it taste bill it's almost
like pasta except their shoelaces you
know put on a brave face
give me times I've made something okay
I've made my wife dinner and she's bit
the first bite she bites into he she
goes mm-hmm-hmm-hmm
and then she runs over and grabs some
salt or something like that I'm just
like it's if I ever a few times
I've ever done that I did it but I think
for the first time since I can ever
remember I did it this year and I was
just one of those nights it was late
night and she was tired and she just
went to the fridge and she usually can
look in there and figure something out
and this time she just didn't and threw
it together and it wasn't good and she
was like how was it I didn't say
anything I just kind of gave her a look
like yeesh and then she immediately she
was just like and then immediately I did
be like no no no it's good it's good
just you know you've made better you
know and then he just fallen down the
hole you're like why did it why
was I honest she does it to me all the
time I thought this was a little
dry
it's like a I feel like I'm on the
Iron Chef when I put something on the
table I mean I'm literally
talking like oatmeal like if I put too
much milk in there should be like it's
too soupy it's too soupy and I want to
be like you know what if it wasn't as
hot as it was if oatmeal wasn't as hot
as it is I would literally dump that
over your head all right what do
you want you were like a food critic
this is actually making me upset I'm
kind of a person another person
makes him a meal and all you do is
criticize it how about you at least yo
hey I really appreciated that you took
the time out to make me a meal that's
one of the most kindest loving things
that one human being could do for
another meeting a human being having
said that I like a little bit less milk
there's no way to criticize it without
coming off like a jerk um just in the
future just to let you know I like a
little less milk by the way making a
homemade cake not that hard it's not
that hard don't be intimidated it's easy
I'm making a pie the pie crust that's a
art making a cake not that
hard I made a three layer cake
and what's going to happen is each layer
is gonna be a little a little I
know I was really hard to try to make
them level I don't know how to do that
yet I'm sure there's something I can
watch on on YouTube but when you go to
make it if you know each layer cake you
know if one's leaning to the left the
others leaning to the right you just
spin them around you put it together
like Legos and know that you're gonna
have frosting in the middle we can kind
of level it out and no one's gonna
notice my mike-mike cake had a little
lean to it
nothing crazy probably the hardest thing
is frosting the cake I started to watch
videos on that but it was just that
she's too full but uh it's just too
boring and there was all this
playoff football on I wanted to watch
that so I probably could have done a
better job with that I don't know I'll
ask my wife god no she'll tell
me right but enough with me complaining
about her complaining right I should I
should be I should be secure enough
my own baking skills no no you did this
one wrong
you know I was trying to because I have
a lot of to talk about this week
other than just being completely blown
away that my daughter's already a year
old I can't believe it and uh I got her
up this morning you know and I just
couldn't believe how big she was and I
was already thinking like she used to be
able to fit like her head would go from
my elbow not even to the tips of my
fingers like I could just hold it just
like that now she just she she's huge
what happened you know there's nothing I
can now see why people have a bunch of
kids because you keep want to hit reset
there's nothing better than having a
baby around your house it's the greatest
it's like a puppy times a million but
what is cool is she's starting to talk
so I'm waiting for these the
conversations with some of the kids my
god they were hilarious
there was this little boy right and he
was talking to this though they wanted
to see like outside my house like along
the side so I go I'll take you over
there just be careful because you know
there's all these concrete steps and
I don't want somebody falling down
so he points to the side of the house he
goes what's this and I go oh that's the
back of the chimney and you know he's a
little kid he goes what's that and then
the little girl answers she goes that's
where Santa Claus comes down and the
smoke goes up when you have a fire then
I think the little kid like the girl and
he goes he says to me goes does she live
here and I started the answer the girl
once again answered the question she
goes no she goes I live out in the
desert and the boy goes in the sand she
goes now
what the heck kid was bombing I was
pulling for him I was like you know say
something funny make a laugh whatever I
just like that he was working on his
game at like four years of age which
reminded me when I was a little kid I
liked this girl who lived in my
neighborhood so I just went over her
house not even invited I just went over
her house knocked on the door think her
name was Michelle
I knocked in the door - mom answers I
was like yeah he's Michelle um she goes
yeah she said they're watching TV and I
go okay so I went in there and I sat
down and watched TV with her her mother
and I think her younger sibling and I
never said a word
for like an hour I just sat there
watching teeth because I didn't know you
know I didn't know what to do and then I
just got up and left
I always wondered what that woman was
second like this little redheaded boy
came over to visit my our daughter today
honey he came in he didn't say a word
then he left
he's an odd little fella anyways alright
let me read a little bit advertising
here for this week
alright Dollar Shave Club Joe I remember
there was another girl I had a crush on
there was these two twins when I was in
first grade and I had a crush on one of
them and the other one had this giant
pen which I thought was a coolest thing
ever even though it was pink it was just
a giant pen which was amazing in the
early 70s like where there was no
computers and she I guess their
wearable computers were gigantic so she
dropped it on the floor and she didn't
realize it and I took it and then I
started writing with it was funny was
the way they had the death set up they
had like us in like little groups of
four and we faced each other and she was
diagonal to me and I'm writing with this
giant pink pen and she's going that's my
pen and I was like no it isn't it's mine
so she's like an idiot then she tells
the teacher
and then she's going Billy is that your
pen and I was like yes and then the
girls go no it was my pen and I was
going no it isn't it's my pen and then
she teaches just like I don't think your
mom would buy you a pink pen and she
took it and gave it back to the girl and
you know there's a little kid like the
embarrassment of that goes away like
eight seconds later you can't even
remember like you know you don't have
like the mental capacity like did I just
really try to pull that off you know why
the would I do that right so then I
remember I went out asked I had to go to
the bathroom so I went out to the
bathroom and her twin sister the one I
had that crush on oh this is like the
next day I went out to go to the
bathroom and her twin sister who I had a
crush on came walking out at the same
time and meet when she saw me she
immediately put her eyebrows down she
goes I heard what you did I heard you
tried to steal my sister's pen and I
just looked at I think I said no I
didn't and I just walked away and that
was the end of that romance oh there's a
lot of sad stories
all right Dollar Shave Club everybody
everyone knows Dollar Shave Club ships
amazing razors for a few bucks
what you might not know is that Douala
shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the
bathroom by the way I was in first grade
when that happened I should think I'm
some weirdo and like the fifth grade
stealing pink pens
all right body wash shampoo hair gel lip
balm everything for a limited time
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their shower shave status set
to new members for only $5 this startup
set features their executive razor and
three trial size versions of their most
popular products that help you stay
fresh so fresh and so clean in your
first box you will receive their shave
butter body wash and one wipe shaly butt
wipes you will also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and full cassette
of cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month
this offers excute exclusively available
at dollarshaveclub.com / birth at
stylish shape club.com / / Dollar Shave
club's high quality products will have
you covered from face cheeks to butt
cheeks there is no better time to try
the club you know what's funny the only
time I notice I have my Invisalign in at
this point is when I go to read this
copy
I already suck at reading out loud but
I've become this Mushmouth jackass by
the way I'm on tray number 7 of 16
Wednesday I go to tray number 8 and I'll
be halfway done well a week from
now be halfway done and I gotta tell you
I'm happy that I'm doing it I'm happy
that I'm doing it you know they don't
like I do for the rest of my life is at
night you're throwing a little
mouth guard to keep the teeth where
they're where they are and all that I
love these I love nice teeth like Farrah
Fawcett you know all white you
know my skin just gets older and older
you know people keep that teeth looking
nice and young so it looks like LED
lights coming out of the Year old
pruned up face all right
movement watches everybody MV MT and
it's that time of year when you could
say I'd like nice watch for no money
alright and it's that time of year again
you thought gift-giving was all over
after Christmas but Valentine's Day is
coming up and you know what that means
that means the guy has to spend money
and the woman does not even though it's
both of your relationships right it's
both of your relationship I should say I
mean if we really want to have
everything equal how about every other
year the lady pays for it right takes
you out for a steak dinner okay blows
you in the back of the uber on the way
home just you know making effort ladies
just making it but Valentine's Day is
coming up so you know you must find the
perfect gift you know what I love about
the fact that I'm already married is I
don't have to deal with the pressure
this horse anymore you know
what I mean that whole where is this
relationship going oh
shut the talk about how you may
have procrastinated in the past or your
own experience with how hard finding the
perfect Valentine's Day gift can be well
you know yo who the knows what a
woman wants right Jesus Christ that
change there's every five seconds and
God knows it's gonna be expensive
what if you don't have a lot of money
and the woman you with you just sort of
bang it then you're not sure if you're
gonna marry her but you got to get her
something nice so she'll keep touching
it right would it be nice to be goodbye
or nice watch but not break the bank
our friends at movement watches the ones
who rebel revolutionize the watch game
have put together the perfect gift guide
to make your life easy whether you're
shopping for him or her yeah like what
women all they're worried about is what
the they're wearing don't decide
you know I really don't like this
holiday by the way don't go out on the
14th go out on the 15th when prices come
back down to what they should be whether
you're shopping for him or her want
watches or their new fashion forward
bracelets sunglasses or any combination
in their limited edition gift box
MVM tea movement watch movements
in-house stylist have curated the most
overly used word ever curated
their trendiest pieces for gift ideas
your special someone will love talk
about how you expand out what do I have
to talk about talk about how you
experience shopping the site looking for
gifts for others movements new watch
styles for her sunglasses and bracelet I
haven't gone to the website alright I'm
married okay which means I have to go
for something more than this high more
high-end than movement watches I
wish movement watches was around when I
was single because what I be surfing
their website right now movement
and their stylists have curated once
again they use the word again an
interactive gift guide to make
Valentine's shopping painless well
somebody should have vetted this copy to
make sure you didn't use that word twice
you can find the perfect gift for him or
her watches bracelets and sunglasses or
any combination of these gifts and a
limited edition gift box
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to move-in watch
this com / / go to movement calm / /
join the movement you know what's
amazing by the way is evidently the
government shutdown and everything still
seems to be working
LegalZoom now that those New Year's
madness is over it's time to work on
your story for 2018 work on your story
okay legalism can help you make this
year this the year you finally get
serious about launching and running your
own business they can also help you rest
a little easier knowing that your
family's future is squared away with the
right it the right estate plan I finally
did this by the way I finally did
this so my family's okay they're gonna
be they're gonna be ok you gotta do it
you gotta do it alright as a
matter of fact LegalZoom has been
helping people just like you take care
of their dreams and responsibilities for
more than 16 years LegalZoom is not a
law firm but they had the resources and
ladies don't be afraid to do this
yourself - you know what I mean be nice
if when you guys kick the bucket we got
a little doremi LegalZoom is not a law
firm and they had the resources to keep
you on the right path including advice
from their nationwide network of
independent attorneys all at your
fingertips whether you want to take your
business to the next level or take
control of your family's future within a
state plan LegalZoom plugs right into
your life without billing you by the
hour because LegalZoom LegalZoom all
pricing is given upfront start writing
your 2018 story at legalzoom.com now and
for a special savings be sure to enter
the promo code burner in the referral
box at check out Legal Zoom where life
meets legal that's legal zone calm and
finally lastly but not leastly
stamps.com
here's a New Year's resolution you can
actually keep at stamps.com to your
business and save a ton of money
this year almost everything you can do
at the post office you could do right
from your desk other than expose
yourself in public because you won't be
in public you
in the privacy of your own home so have
you junk out while you do this plus
stamps comm is posted discounts you can
get you can't get at the post office not
to mention it's a fraction of the cost
of those super expensive postage meters
stamps.com sends you a digital scale
that automatically calculates the exact
postage you will never overpay or under
pay for postage again got the hiccups
here create your stamps calm account in
minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long-term commitments
keyword descriptors know this stamps.com
is convenient it's easy it's reliable
and efficient I use stamps com anytime I
send my posters you know if I'm gonna
sell my posters out you know at the end
of the my shows what am I trying when I
myself out I'm gonna sell posters
at the end of the show I use stamps com
to get them there and I'm a so if
I can figure it out so can you do not be
intimidated by this technology and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps comm
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale ready for a happier
New York go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps.com enter
ber but boop boop is a story of a bald
head freckled alright alright let's
read some questions here for the week
and let's get going Billy you stupid la
alright here we go
you never mentioned why exactly you
moved to LA I didn't know I was required
to why did you move to LA I just
listened to you and jim Florentine
/ Florentine he said and Florentine said
he didn't see a difference with
comedians in New York City I find it
hard to imagine that la oh god this guy
I find it hard to amounting to read
exactly what I wrote I find it hard to
imagine that la there are a lot less
in the audience that get offended
too easily you then agreed with Jim that
maybe it's because you now live there
and are used to it but the way you said
it
didn't seem believable so what's the
deal alright like there wasn't one
capital letter no punctuation whatsoever
a couple of periods maybe I'm not
required to tell you why moved
out here but I will to eat up some time
I was living in New York I was just sick
of being there it just it just gets a
point where you know you get to be told
too old and you're like I can't live
like an animal anymore
which means you're either gonna move
outside the city or in my business
you're gonna go to LA and I had nothing
going on in my career other than the
Opie and Anthony show but the writing
was on the wall with that show where you
know those guys like they had a bunch of
comics on and I was one of them Jim
Norton got us all in and you know there
was no money in the budget to pay us but
the way that they paid us Opie and
Anthony show because they the salt of
the earth they used to run
advertisements of our gigs and then our
gigs would sell out and it was great but
then the corporate there said that
they couldn't do it anymore you know so
then he kind of had to hype your show
during the show which would get in the
way of you know whatever craziness was
going on so that's kind of where my
career was that I was on a radio show
and I wasn't getting paid I wasn't
getting any acting work and the only way
I was getting paid on the Opie and
Anthony show they no longer let them do
for whatever reason which is really
short-sighted on Sirius XM's side
because Opie and Anthony were this
launching pad for stand-up careers and
they will make it like they made us
become like these drawers
and then that would then feed back into
the show because then these people was
selling all these tickets were like hey
I'm gonna be the open T show so it you
know you know wait what is it totally
worked it was the perfect
relationship for about three years and
then like what always happens is the
money people come in and they the
whole thing up so I mean that's not the
only reason I was I was leaving but
that's basically that was his high up as
I got in New York I was on a radio show
not getting paid that's the best I could
do I had already done an episode of Law
& Order so you know and I couldn't get
on The Sopranos because that was a bunch
of battalions and I look like
yeah Billy red face over here so there
was like no opportunity left for me and
I was going down to the Comedy Cellar
like every single night and it was like
it was like Groundhog Day and I just you
know and I went out to LA and I hated LA
and I just came out here and I started
to each time I went out I was starting
to like it and I was fighting that
feeling and I don't know I just said
it one day it's like you know what
I wouldn't mind living in an apartment
paying a ton of money but I could
actually have like a couch that also
wasn't my bed I wouldn't mind having a
car I moved out here I had this
apartment it was still a one-bedroom but
I had front and back stairs the back
stairs I did share with my neighbor but
still that was amazing to me and I had a
garage where I could park my car and
even though the traffic was
horrific just the fact that I could live
a little more like a human being again
was appealing and then there was a ton
of acting work out here that I could
potentially get and I moved out here and
within the first year I got on Breaking
Bad so that's why I came out here but I
do have to tell you that the that I
thought when I came out here that the
comedy scene was horrific
so what I was trying to say on the
podcast is when I go back to the New
York now it's just like it's just I
think it's just changed but because I'm
not there every day I noticed the change
and out here last night you know I was
telling a couple of jokes and there was
silence so maybe that's what it was I
don't know why you took it so so
personally but that is a big
thing the whole East Coast West Coast
thing I do however I'm one of those
weird people that I do love both coasts
but you know I don't know I'm kind of
out here right now I used to think like
I'll always move back but now I don't I
don't know that I will who knows I don't
know I have no idea I was kind
of thinking with global warming
eventually I was going to hit was gonna
have to move back there but now it seems
like it's gonna be all crazy weather so
the fact that it was hot out here now
it's gonna be extremely hot and the fact
that it was cold back there now it's
going to be extremely cold and I
don't know I did like 40 something
winters back east okay I put my time in
alright I'd rather shovel out of a
mudslide packed in the snow so there you
go all right
all right bill my problems with women
this is funny he wrote my problems with
woman Oh
my problems with woman dear Bill's
buried oh boy oh I love that one all
right I'm a huge fan from I don't even
know how to say this fer ma n agh fer
man na nog I don't know Ireland Ireland
I'm 17 years old and have always been a
fat well that's good man you're
looking at yourself honestly no let's
what can we do about this recently I
lost the weight and started getting into
the gym there you go I'm now 6-1 and 200
pounds so naturally have started getting
more female attention alright this is
all good I was never been
I was never been successful with women
but now I'm turning this franchise
around there you go well dude you're
only 17 if you're just getting out of
the gate here my only problem is I'm a
quiet guy and don't know how to talk to
them they seem to just want to talk
about or gossip and meaningless
crap oh god dude you can't be this
cynical at 17 you sound like me right
now and I'm gonna be 50 I try and be
funny and make them laugh which can only
get me so far I can't maintain a
relationship because they open their
mouths and I contemplate suicide Jesus
you sound like a writer are you creative
or something or you think too much I
consider myself as straightforward no BS
kind of guy but I'm just a wanker it's
just a problem with me or them I don't
hate women I just don't get along with
them if possible I would love to hear
what Nia has to say oh she wouldn't like
how you worded all of this thanks Bill
and go yourself PS if you're
getting into soccer I suggest you
support either Tottenham or Liverpool as
they have young exciting teams and
aren't soulless corporate entities like
Chelsea or Man City oh I didn't know
that
all right I'll support Liverpool then
it's where the Beatles are from right I
don't it no way anyways alright
what's your problem I don't know I think
you're a little defensive I think you're
a little insecure so you're kind of
projecting on them I know that that's
what I did so I would say open yourself
up a little bit more and you know
realize how amazing they are
but women are just like men the good one
is hard to find good woman hard to find
so you're only 17 and I think also
trying to make them laugh is always a
good thing and what I've learned is a
lot of times they just want you to
listen and they don't want you to try to
solve their problems
so just you know when they tell a story
hold both their hands and be like oh my
god I don't know why would you ask me
like I know anything about women Jesus
Christ they hate me my fan base
is a sausage fest I got to give
you more advice than that yeah dude yeah
this is a weakness of mine understanding
women I have no idea you just basically
I don't know it's like writing Charlie
Manson being like hey how do I get along
with people a little more a little more
better I'm just probably better example
Frank did he just die what a
life huh what a life I just
can't imagine spending that much time in
jail like you're never getting out again
you're in your 30s you're never getting
out again like I and I just sitting
there like really you gotta be
kidding me
fascinating guy and in all the wrong
reason you think you really like I
literally never commit as far as we know
never committed a murder but was such a
lunatic I've never seen a horror
movie we're all a guy had to do was just
whisper in somebody's ear or something
like that and then they just
would just do whatever the guy said just
had that a bit like literally the
devil he spent his whole life
you know just imagine if he ever you
know he got Micky Dolenz his part on the
Monkees it's unreal
if somebody like Hitler's drawings so
you have to encourage people all right
westerns everybody dear Billy Sundance
Billy the Sundance okay I've been just
getting into Western I wasn't a huge fan
as a kid I was more into space and
futuristic stuff but as I round my
mid-20s and I'm living more of a loner
life I'm starting to connect more I'm
really looking for
to the new Christian Bale movie hostiles
I can't wait to see that I hope I said
that correctly because I loved 3:10 to
Yuma
I loved the original to my other
favorites are tombstone and Butch
Cassidy I was hoping to hear which one
your favorites are and get some
recommendations to watch while I'm
snowed in for the next four days all the
best to you and your family I would say
the Clint Eastwood's the spaghetti
westerns Fistful of Dollars the good the
bad and the ugly
he had like a trilogy of those the
Outlaw Josey Wales you know I hate to
say this but I've never seen the
Unforgiven that was right when I started
doing stand-up and I just started
missing out on
I like those The Wild Bunch
let's see the Magnificent Seven
the original West world there's one that
combines futurist futuristic
they're sci-fi and westerns the old
Brenner is incredible in that you'll
Brennan one of my favorites of all time
not because he's bald like me but I just
thought he was the I never saw
Butch Cassidy the Sundance Kid yeah I
think that I would say that that that
was all of them my name's never quite
into the John Wayne one so those ones
were too far back in the day I like the
ones from like the 60s
I like those and I liked all the war
movies Kelly's heroes Dirty Dozen bridge
over River Kwai all of that so
those are my recommendations I would go
with the Clint Eastwood spaghetti
westerns alright my life's my
life sorry my life this
sounds like a sitcom right oh the
battery did the battery just died oh the
battery's gonna die and I'll I got
to wrap this up alright my life
if I don't get through all this thank
you to everybody for listening
duh once again congratulations to the
Patriots and the Eagles and
congratulations to the Jaguars and the
Vikings on two great seasons all right
four great seasons here right my puck
life dear Bill and Nia I'm 17 and still
in high school I'm a bit of a I'm in a
bit of a pickle what the is wrong
with this thing
it keeps beeping I think I'm falling for
my best friend I realized after we were
falling asleep at her house she had just
taken off her makeup and made a joke
like sorry I looked so bad but when I
looked at her thought she looks so
beautiful and cute in her sweatshirt
that was just a little too big for her
what is his Flashdance however she's
currently dating a well what the
are you doing over our house all
right I'm back I guess my recorder was
almost filled up sorry about that
now I had to edit two things
together as always as always making my
life difficult anyways yeah so what are
you doing over this person's house she's
dating somebody else
anyway she goes he's a loser no job
still gets an allowance an expensive
card that his mommy bought him sits at
home all day playing video games getting
stoned and treats people like he's above
them she knows I hate him and I openly
mock him in front of our friends her and
even him like he got her this really
generic but expensive looking
heart-shaped necklace when she showed it
to everyone I looked at him and said
loudly Wow must have cost your mom quite
a big whatever that means as you can
imagine he tries to avoid me yeah well
you're being a we share the
same friends and they hate him and like
me but mind you I'm no prize either I'm
trying to get a job unlike him out Jesus
you don't even have a job and
then saving up for a car so her choices
are two guys who don't have a job and
she has a rich mom well there you go
I tend to be nice a nice guy
but can at times piss people off with my
jokes and even be a dick with my jokes
you sound like you're being a dick I'm
not saying you are but you're being a
dick to this guy he's at least three
inches taller than me and handsomer
better-looking I guess he's got this
great smile that makes me want to
him up for sure
well that makes me want to it up
for him but recently I've started to
turn my life around quit beer porn and
drugs
my grades are going up applying for
college working out a lot but all this
in hopes of catching her ride like I
said she's my best friend and as a
boyfriend so I really don't know how to
handle this any help from you and Neil
would be greatly appreciated yeah dude I
would start fishing in a different
watering hole all right you know for you
to sit there and stand there and be a
to her boyfriend talking about a
boyfriend and you're going over that for
over a house it sounds to me
like you're the you're less Chris Rock
says you're in the friend zone
so what you need that what you need is
you need some time away from her all
right move on with your life
keep working out get your going and
who knows you might just meet somebody
else and then eventually when she dumps
this loser she comes around and sees you
she oh my God look at you you're going
to college
you look great you've been working out
you know watch porn
who knows maybe it'll happen but I can
tell you it's definitely not gonna
happen if you could just gonna be your
friend then making snide remarks about
her boyfriend come on you got to be
better than that that's just coming off
like you know you're acting like a
you're acting like a douche dee
and I don't know how else to put it
that's not a strong move all right and
you should have more going on in your
life than the could be you know you
still have more self-esteem than that
all right okay she wants to date this
guy guess what it's her loss
all right it's a get on with
your life keep working out and work out
for yourself go to college for yourself
do all this for yourself feel good
about yourself you start putting out
more of a positive vibe it's supposed to
you know hanging around her on
her current boyfriend I mean that's just
like I don't know that's not a good look
okay I believe in you all right do what
I just said
or don't because I don't have any
professional training
all right dumping my girlfriend a billy
billboard brow like
that's another good one recent Fandi a
podcast stand-up in all that jazz
anyways I'm a 24 year old dude and I've
been dating and living with my girl for
almost four years now and I finally had
enough she's a real downer and talk
about people including her friends like
it's an Olympic sport
now the problem is she lost a job a
month ago on account of her talking
he hasn't exactly been going out and
looking for a new one because she's
anxious or whatever leaving me to pick
up her end of the bills she didn't have
any savings because she had picked up
the habit of going out and drinking
every night I honestly wouldn't have a
problem just up and leaving but the
apartment is a stone's throw from the
beach and my other roommate and I really
don't want to leave the
decisions people make it's right near
the beach the other roommate is my best
friend okay she's got a lot of books and
and the bed is hers so wouldn't be
a little so would be a little difficult
to do the old put all her stuff in a box
trick
deep down I do still have love for her
so the idea of kicking her out hurts my
heart but I just can't deal with the
endless drama and unhappiness would love
to hear what your advice on the podcasts
and as always go yourself
yeah the relationship has run its course
and you need to go your separate ways
and sometimes when that happens you know
somebody yes somebody
it's hurt alright but you're not doing
her any favors if you don't want her to
be with you and you just you just
wasting her in your time so you know
this is why you don't live with
somebody unless you know you're gonna
marry them I don't know I don't know
good boy
so what do you do break up with her and
then tell her to move out all at the
same time or those two separate
conversations I just break up with her
and then let her bring up where am I
gonna live and I'd be like well I don't
know I mean the coastline is pretty long
so I'm sure there's another beachfront
apartment you could be in I'm assuming
your names on the lease usually when
there's a breakup the guy has to leave
and leave half his so it seems like
you're in a decent position here who
wants a negative drunk without a job I
don't think you want that doesn't sound
like you want it I think the love you
have for her was who she used to be or
who you thought she was so neither of
those are happening right now so it's
time for you to tell her to hit the
bricks Happy New Year sweetheart beat it
you can't say it like that I just tell
her look we need to talk and sit down
she could be what's the problem well it
was the problem me and you just got a
bike through that horrible
feeling there's nothing worse the only
worse than a woman crying is when she's
about to cry because you still have hope
that she's not gonna cry
so you're on pins and needles once she's
crying you're like a this sucks but
you kind of know what's gonna happen
yeah you just got to sit it down and
just say listen I'm not happy this isn't
working for me anymore and we need to
break up all right just like that boom
boom boom and you got to get that out
you got to get all of that out don't sit
there and be like
I don't know how to say this editor then
turn it into a 45-minute thing rip the
band-aid on just rip it off we need to
talk I'm not happy we need to break up
okay
you're going to the two-minute offense
get don't get out of Bounce you keep the
clock running you want this game to be
over no I don't know yeah that's what I
would do that's what I would do just sit
down and just say all right in eight
seconds this relationship is gonna be
over okay I'm on this side Rob of the
eight seconds all I do how long does it
take to say that I'm at time it right
now
all right We Need to Talk I'm not happy
we need to break up I just did that in
like five seconds and then she what if
we blow up a lot no I've made the
decision we need to break up it's just
it's just not working for me I don't
love you the way I used to love you
that's it what can I say about they can
get mad they can cry they can do all
that but the thing is you conveyed
it and you're out where am I gonna live
I don't know we'll figure that I guess
that's the next thing we need to figure
out yeah well is your life gonna suck
after that but it's never gonna suck
more than staying in a
relationship you don't want to be in
alright and that's one to grow on
go yourselves I'll talk to you on
Thursday all right I'm back I guess my
the quarter was almost filled up sorry
about that
now I had to edit two things
together as always as always making my
life difficult anyways yeah so what are
you doing over this person's house she's
dating somebody else
anyway she goes he's a loser no job
still gets an allowance an expensive
card that his mommy bought him sits at
home all day playing video games getting
stoned and treats people like he's above
them she knows I hate him and I openly
mock him in front of our friends her and
even him
like he got her this really generic but
expensive looking heart-shaped necklace
when she showed it to everyone I looked
at him and said loudly Wow must have
cost your mom quite a big whatever that
means as you can imagine he tries to
avoid me yeah well you're being a
we share the same friends
and they hate him and like me but mind
you I'm no prize either I'm trying to
get a job unlike him out Jesus you don't
even have a job and then saving
up for a car so her choices are two guys
who don't have a job and she has a rich
mom well there you go
I tend to be nice a nice guy but can at
times piss people off with my jokes and
even be a dick with my jokes you sound
like you're being a dick I'm not saying
you are but you're being a dick to this
guy he's at least three inches taller
than me and handsomer better-looking I
guess he's got this great smile that
makes me want to him up for sure
well that makes me want to it up
for him but recently I've started to
turn my life around quit beer porn and
drugs
my grades are going up applying for
college working out a lot but all this
in hopes of catching her ride like I
said she's my best friend and as a
boyfriend so I really don't know how to
handle this any help from you and Neil
would be greatly appreciated yeah dude I
would start fishing in a different
watering hole all right you know for you
to sit there and stand there and be a
to her boyfriend
talking about her boyfriend and you're
going over that for over a house
it sounds to me like you're the ural as
Chris Rock says you're in the friend
zone so what you need what you need is
you need some time away from her all
right move on with your life
keep working out get your going and
who knows you might just meet somebody
else
and then eventually when she dumps this
loser she comes around and sees you she
my god look at you you going to college
you look great you've been working out
you know watch porn
who knows maybe it'll happen but I can
tell you it's definitely not gonna
happen
if you could just gonna be your friend
then making snide remarks about her
boyfriend come on do you got to be
better than that that's just coming off
like you know you're acting like a
you're acting like a douche Dee
and I don't know how else to put it
that's not a strong move all right and
you should have more going on in your
life then the could be you know you
should have more self-esteem than that
all right okay she wants to date this
guy guess what it's her loss all
right
it's a get on with your life
keep working out and work out for
yourself go to college for yourself do
all this for yourself feel good
about yourself you start putting out
more of a positive vibe it's supposed to
you know hanging around her on
her current boyfriend I mean that's just
like I don't know that's not a good look
okay
I believe in you all right do what I
just said
or don't because I don't have any
professional training
all right dumping my girlfriend a billy
billboard brow like
that's another good one recent Fandi a
podcast stand-up in all that jazz
anyways I'm a 24 year old dude and I've
been dating and living with my girl for
almost four years now and I finally had
enough she's a real downer and talk
about people including her friends like
it's an Olympic sport now the problem is
she lost a job a month ago on account of
her talking he hasn't exactly been
going out and looking for a new one
because she's anxious or whatever
leaving me to pick up her end of the
bills she didn't have any savings
because she had picked up the habit of
going out and drinking every night I
honestly wouldn't have a problem just up
and leaving but the apartment is a
stone's throw from the beach and my
other roommate
and I really don't want to leave the
decisions people make it's right
near the beach the other roommate is my
best friend okay she's got a lot of
books and and the bed is hers so
wouldn't be a little so it would be a
little difficult to do the old put all
her stuff in a box trick
deep down I do still have love for her
so the idea of kicking her out hurts my
heart but I just can't deal with the
endless drama and unhappiness we'd love
to hear what your advice on the podcasts
and as always go yourself yeah do
you know the relationship has run its
course and you need to go your separate
ways and sometimes when that happens you
know somebody yes somebody gets hurt
alright but you're not doing her any
favors if you don't want her to be with
you and you just you just wasting her in
your time so you know this is why you
don't live with somebody unless
you know you're gonna marry them I don't
know I don't know good boy
[Music]
so what do you do break up with her and
then tell her to move out all at the
same time or those two separate
conversations I just break up with her
and then let her bring up where am I
gonna live and I'd be like well I don't
know I mean the coastline is pretty long
so I'm sure there's another beachfront
apartment you could be in I'm assuming
your name's on the lease usually when
there's a breakup the guy has to leave
and leave half his so it seems like
you're in a decent position here who
wants a negative drunk without a job I
don't think you want that doesn't sound
like you want it I think the love you
have for her was who she used to be or
who you thought she was so neither of
those are happening right now so it's
time for you to tell her to hit the
bricks happy new year sweetheart beat it
you can't say it like that I just tell
it look we need to talk
and sit down she could be what's the
problem well what's the problem he and
he's got a fight through that
horrible feeling
there's nothing worse the only worse
than a woman crying is when she's about
to cry because you still have hope that
she's not gonna cry
so you're on pins and needles once she's
crying you're like a this sucks but
you kind of know what's gonna happen
yeah you just got to sit her down and
just say listen I'm not happy this isn't
working for me anymore
and we need to break up all right just
like that boom boom boom and you got to
get that out you got to get all of that
out don't sit there and be like girl I
don't know how to say this then turn it
into a 45 minute thing rip the band-aid
on just rip it off we need to talk I'm
not happy we need to break up okay
you're going to the two-minute offense
okay don't get out of bounds you keep
the clock running you want this game to
be over no I don't know yeah that's what
I would do that's what I would do just
sit down and just say all right in eight
seconds this relationship is going to be
over okay I'm on this side robbed of the
eight seconds all I do
how long does it take to say that I'm
gonna time it right now all right We
Need to Talk
I'm not happy we need to break up I just
did that in like five seconds and then
she what if we blow up a lot no I've
made the decision we need to break up
it's just it's just not working for me I
don't love you the way I used to love
you that's it what can they say about
they can get mad they can cry they can
do all that but the thing is you
conveyed it and you're out where am I
gonna live I don't know we'll figure
that I guess that's the next thing we
need to figure out and well is your life
going to suck after that
it's never gonna suck more than staying
in a relationship you don't want
to be in alright and that's one to grow
on
go yourselves I'll talk to you on
Thursday